[Music]
every major esport has its share of
iconic maps
if you've got a good map or two you're
halfway to having an esport that will
stand the test of
time unfortunately though not all maps
are created
equal some of them just really miss the
mark
and what's even worse is that some of
them don't get removed
they just hang around like a bad smell
and
won't leave but before we get into that
guys make sure you are subscribed to the
channel so you don't miss a video
just like this one and with that let's
get into the top 10
most hated maps in esports
rolling in at number 10 like a limp
tumbleweed is everyone's favorite rush
bee
fever dream dust2
rush long rust b rush long rust be [ __ ]
off dust2 is one of the oldest esports
maps of all time it's beloved by many
but
hated by more that's
all right that's uncharacteristic we'll
forget that ever happened nobody clip
that let's uh
yeah let's move along oh
although a classic dust2's design has
hardly ever been touched since its first
appearance
20 years ago and with 20 years of play
pros have developed some extremely valid
criticism
like how mid doors absolutely suck
they absolutely need kinetic out to such
a hot start and that is
really brutal the confidence there and
and you know
i don't know oh no not one more time
ethan again with his teammates being
taken oh my god this time with the creek
it's so brutal it's stannis oh he hasn't
even been able to play the game
you see ct's need to cross mid doors to
get to b
but that means they have to spend
utility if they don't want to get awked
but if it's an a hit they need to do the
exact same thing
to cross mid doors again the map is
basically a coin flip
and one death can lead to some pretty
brutal situations
can they actually get a kill initially
yes
yeah i think that might be peachy so yes
dust2 is probably the most important map
in fbs history
but it's also a dinosaur that's more
than worn out it's welcome
skating into our ninth spot is the
coldest map on our list
icebox that's right valerian is only a
year old and it already has one of the
worst
maps we've ever seen great start riot
it's going to be hard though
it's impossible it's impossible it's
literally impossible to retake that side
yeah you see what i'm saying why i hate
this map
you see what i'm saying why i hate this
map i'm peaking an angle they can be on
top of five different
there are so many different boxes ledges
catwalks and tubes that it's almost
nauseating trying to figure out what
angle you're going to get peaked from
and oh you want to retake a site have
fun checking
every single corner of the damn map all
right i want you to watch me clear this
this site okay i'm looking at the zip
line i'm looking over here got to look
up here
look at how many places i could get shot
from bro
also b-side is non-existent unless you
run sage and the viper
defenders get to hold some insane angles
that essentially force attackers to hit
a
every time don't believe me ask
immortals who hit
a 12 times in a row at first strike yo
dash i'll let you know now i thought i
was going crazy man immortals they went
a for like the first
i said okay they're gonna leave space to
go to b that didn't happen at all
to get our eight spot on the list we're
gonna have to take a little trip to the
city of love
[Laughter]
no yeah uh paris paris and
horizon are definitely in the note here
i mean they are literally not even in
the game
at the moment they're so bad blizzard
just removed them from the game
overwatch's rendition of paris
is the absolute worst map in the game
all thanks to its
insane choke points minute and a half
remaining
jump forward yakbong trying to stay out
of line of sight here but the rest of
the squad gonna be taking down ivy and
roki
both eliminated now envy is out of the
back he can't get out of the room yeah
you could hear those clangs for just a
moment that was the deflect coming
through from ivy
unfortunately just a little bit too late
there to get the last damage in
because of the two brutal choke points
defenders basically have a free win if
they play a bunker comp
on top of that attackers are hit with
some of the longest walk times from
spawn to the first point
in the entire game so getting team wiped
ensures you'll be playing death
stranding for the next 45 seconds i
don't know what the
so the walk time to this first point is
absolutely insane huh
they feel like they're really far away
but they spawn all the way back there
right and they have to walk
all the way like can a ryan can charge
at a spawn right all the way his charge
gets like here right
but then he saw it's like he saw us go
all the way there
paris was quickly removed from the
competitive map paul
soon after it was released the community
was pleased but many were still confused
about how this one even made it into the
game in the first place
for lucky number seven let's head over
to rocket league now
more specifically old neo tokyo where
you can experience some immaculate vibes
brilliant architecture and bumpers
oh my god we're playing neo turkey i'd
rather like
blow my brain out and play oh
neo tokyo is a unique stadium because it
has two levels of play
most of the field is normal but along
each side is a raised wall that players
need to either
drive or jump onto fans thought the
double decker style was a fun addition
to the casual experience
but then neo tokyo became the first
double decker map to make its way into
ranked play
and it was a mess basically immediately
so comfortable on this map you can tell
they practiced and the fact that they
know how to use the edges gives them
that much wider of an aerial space to
use genesis
didn't really know what to do i think
with those ledges like we were talking
about that's a big change
with neo tokyo and they weren't really
sure what to do we saw a lot of the
contests that they were
having up there on the ledges they were
losing out to moses and turtle according
to psionics the map was supposed to add
a level of complexity
and require more strategy from veteran
players
but all it did was cause a clown fiesta
anytime the ball hopped onto the ledge
it turned the ball trajectory into one
big
guessing game and players who dedicated
their time to perfecting moves
felt the ledges were just one big
gimmick i love the colors i don't like
the side stuff i hate getting because
you
you pop up there yeah it's so awkward
being up here
at the end of it all neo tokyo was
banished to rocket labs after
one season of play and as a result the
devs made sure that every competitive
map
was set to a default size and structure
fortunately
neo tokyo was eventually reworked so at
least we can still appreciate that
beautiful architecture
blaming our number six spot is the map
beyond saving
new hereford base god damn it we got it
these these goddamn [ __ ] run here
for it rainbow six siege has a lot of
maps that deserve a place on this list
so many that we dedicated an entire list
of them two years
ago now a lot of things have changed
since 2019
but new hereford base is not one of
those things
ever since ubisoft royally picked up the
map's rework
it's been one of the most universally
hated maps in
siege watch out for the peak holes that
they made
hereford base is an attacker's nightmare
first off it's well dark as [ __ ] now
that wouldn't be too bad if the map
wasn't also
an absolute maze you could play for
hours and still get lost
i don't even know where we're at this is
insane this is
this is not this is not my hereford base
even the devs don't know what to do with
it uh hereford we were
okay so
hereford rework was a dumpster fire
falling into fifth place is probably the
buggiest map on this list
pokemon stadium johnny stalker we're
gonna see club go up 2-0
for the first time could we see oh what
the hell
are you kidding me the pokemon glitch
in top eight and shine unreal
freeze this map the right side is more
beneficial for mars because this bear
appears the smash goes pretty much the
entire almost the entire length
what what what did he dive through
he just fell through the stage that
happens this is stupid
what happens i can't believe it actually
happened
i missed that that's right there's an
unexplainable issue with the map's code
that causes a player to just
fall through the map when it transforms
into the fire pokemon stage
but it doesn't stop there because
there's a ton
of character specific issues and the
other transformations
also cause problems like the rock
formation that lets some characters do
infinite combos that's stuck this is it
is it is active go in on this
transformation oh
there's nothing you do that is real you
gotta take the damage
eventually the problems got so out of
hand that a lot of tournaments started
using a modded version of the map that
simply
wouldn't transform the call of duty
franchise has pumped out
countless games since 2003 and hundreds
of maps too
but our number four has to go to the
worst of them all
piccadilly
just like it's real life location
piccadilly is a bustling intersection in
downtown london
it's filled with stores double decker
buses and the famous
underground tube but all these things
that make london a popular tourist spot
make this map a living hell piccadilly i
swear to god i swear to god i'm not even
trying to be funny
okay i will walk around my house and
just be like piccadilly
like i can't believe it exists yo the
developers
cater 1 000 to campers
in this game it's irrefutable i mean
they already said they made the maps for
noobs they wanted noobs to have
safe spaces they're catering to slow
tactical gameplay
that's why all the doorways and windows
and corners are dark you can't see
nobody infinity ward what the heck is
wrong with you people man
it doesn't stop there either this map
somehow feels both gigantic and
claustrophobic
all at the same time and maybe worst of
all
are the spawns you're usually dropped
into one of the ends of the street and
all your enemy has to do
is hole up with a good enough gun and
spawn camp the [ __ ] out of you
easy this is the only place we're gonna
hold down now because they got a chopper
gunner
this the chopper gunner so this the only
place they can come for safety and
they're still trapped
that's the only place they can come for
safety check
this is the only place they can come for
safety flying into the number three spot
is
none other than lilat cola for waiting
or buzz just
oh what
what um no ban li
lat laila is one of the most hated maps
in smash history and for multiple
reasons
for starters many are turned off by the
geometry of the map
it's a flying ship that tilts and turns
which causes a lot of problems for
players trying to make it back on stage
with those angles
and if you if you ever played uh rosa
her um
the angles under upbeat it's like kind
of strange
more importantly lilac is hated for its
ledges more specifically
it's baffling lack of them
all right oh a good backer
cloud fights for the tourney pot i can
believe it oh unfortunate
why lilac
[Music]
or whatever the negative version of the
runner-up is
goes to vertigo the worst map in cs go
vertigo [ __ ] that [ __ ] where do we even
start with this nightmare map it's got
tons of sound issues
and bugs but the biggest issue is that
it's csgo's most
vertical map which causes a lot of
problems
closer and closer to overtime oh no
he has done it
it's also an absolute maze that gives
defenders angles and boosts that don't
exist
anywhere else in the game wait oh my god
i see him i see him wait i see him wait
no no
i got him let's go
he's so mad he's gonna message me on
steam bro it forces t's to hit a
every single time giving the defenders a
chance to flank using one of the many
ladders or just chill on site and dunk
maids all day
and to the gold nova 3 watching this
video yes
vertigo actually does suck you don't
really love it
you might think you have a big brain but
you're either delusional or you buy a
p90
every round on ct face it the map is a
mess
last and certainly least the worst map
in esports history
is tower no
no no
no
not only is tower the worst map in
rainbow six siege and competitive gaming
in general
it might just be the worst piece of
media ever created
i think it's the worst map they've ever
designed it has no vertical play
it is huge defenders have a field day
roaming on it
i i there's not a lot of setups you can
do on it
that makes it unique there's like no
diversity
you know you set it up everything tower
tries to do
it fails at first of all attackers are
basically forced to rappel down the side
of the tower and
jump through a window or drop down a
tiny elevator shaft
and all that work doesn't even get you
onto a sight
that just gets you into the building
but once you're in your problems have
only just begun
now you need to check every possible
angle for roma's because defenders don't
actually need to defend the sight on
tower they can literally be
anywhere else and still win the round
that was a headshot pros hate it casuals
hate it
you hate it my parents don't even know
what esports are and they probably
[ __ ] hate it
what how wait you're telling me i have
to drone the floor below
now to be able to repel to the safety of
the balcony
oh my god just another reason why i love
tower alright guys there you go those
were our most hated maps
in esports history did any of them make
your blood boil
were there any good ones or awful ones
that we really should have included on
the list
let us know thanks for watching guys as
always and i'll see you all
in the next look super one
opera i really like her oh
i killed myself what it just happened
dude
what just happened
this guy just hit fire i hate blitz dude
i hate him i [ __ ] hate this operator
ubisoft what the [ __ ] is this operator